Placentas are strange alien-looking pancake-shaped
life-support organ for a fetus, but once that
baby is born...
I'm hungry, DIBS!
There are people out there who eat the placenta
after birth.
Some are celebrities, some are just weirdos
like you and me, and some are completely normal.
But placentophagy, as it's known in the scientific
world, doesn't seem to have the benefits claimed
by the people who eat it.
Look, science can take the fun out of anything,
so why not this too?
Humans are among a few animals who DON'T practice
placentophagia -- almost all land mammals
eat the afterbirth.
And that fact is a common one people cite
when they DO eat placentas.
Though the ones who don't are pretty telling...
chimpanzees and scavengers don't, and a study
of 179 cultures found basically zero evidence
of placentophagy in any historic or prehistoric
human cultures!
I mean, maybe during a famine, sure, but otherwise,
nah.
Why?
A study in Ecology and Food Nutrition says,
"[If] placentophagia is not a biologically
determined behavior in humans, we should assume
that there must be a good adaptive reason
for its elimination."
Placentas aren't some purple sack of miracles.
They’re part of the fetal life-support system,
which also includes the amniotic sac and umbilical
cord.
The placenta attaches to the uterus, allowing
the transfer of nutrients and oxygen from
the mother's blood to the fetal blood -- keeping
them separate.
It protects against bacterial -- not viral
-- infections and passes antibodies to the
baby creating three months of immune response
at birth… like a 90-day warranty!
It also produces pregnancy hormones like estrogen,
progesterone, and hCG.
After the birth, the placenta is ejected,
in what's called the afterbirth.
The placenta is a life-support filter, so
it can contain high levels of bacteria, selenium,
cadmium, mercury, or lead.
It can also still contain many of the hormones
for its fetal charge which can cause any number
of effects if ingested.
And yet, People claim eating their placentas
balanced their hormones, kept them from developing
postpartum depression, boosted their energy,
helped them regain nutrients, or stopped their
bleeding immediately after birth!
The most scientific sounding research has
to do with pain relief after birth.
A 1986 study from the University at Buffalo
found an opioid-enhancing molecule in amniotic
fluid and in the placenta which promoted quote
"maternal behavior" in RATS, and another study
also from U-B in 2005 found placentophagia
may have analgesic -- or pain killing -- properties
for rats.
One researcher believes, some of the claimed
natural energy buzz and the possible lessening
of the baby blues COULD have to do with the
hormones in the placenta, but again, there's
no evidence whatsoever either way; and if
that's the case, it would be better to treat
the postpartum depression than eat an organ
that may not do so.
In the end, though, there's just not really
any new double-blind controlled studies on
placental ingestions.
There's a LOT of anecdotal information out
there and a TON of media attention, but it's
not a common practice, one hospital in DC
found of 3,500 annual births only two mothers
took their placenta home in a year.
So there's no hard evidence to support whether
it's bad OR good.
If you DO go for it, just remember it's meat,
and bacteria can infect meat; so eating it
raw can be dangerous.
It
is meat grown even if it's grown by a human
fetus, after all.
Anyway, if you go for it; you do you, people.